tonight the choice at this election has
been clear you can walk for the same old
parties and get the same old politics
more cuts and more misguided priorities
or you can vote for something different
better and more progressive I'm going
into this election with a clear message
none of us can afford more austerity
none of us can afford an additional 30
billion pounds of cuts and none of us
can afford the 100 billion pounds that
the Tories labored and liberals intend
to spend on new nuclear weapons their
priorities are wrong but they won't pay
the price it will be ordinary people
across the country who pay the price the
SNP offers an alternative a clear
alternative a plan for investment yes it
is fiscally responsible but it will also
allow us to invest in infrastructure to
protect our public services until lift
people out of poverty to people in
Scotland I say vote SNP for a loader
voice for Scotland to people elsewhere I
see ours will be a voice to help bring
about change for you to metro station
Thank You Nick Clegg well thank you for
sitting through this to our political
marathon I just have one more thing to
ask of you and it is this when you vote
make sure that you decide what's right
for you and your family make sure that
you do what's right for our country but
above all make sure that we don't lurch
this way or that make sure that we don't
borrow too much on the one hand or cut
too much on the other in other words
make sure that when you vote we keep our
country stable and strong and fair and
the only way we can do that is by
finishing the job finishing it fairly
balancing the books doing it fairly and
putting money into our public services
because that's the only way that we can
create the society that I imagine we all
want a society where we have a stronger
economy and a fairer society where there
is opportunity for everyone
Nick Clegg's thank you Ed Miliband
you've heard from seven leaders tonight
but there's one fundamental choice of
this election do we build a Britain that
puts working people first
do we carry on with the government
that's not on your side if I'm Prime
Minister I'll make sure we reward the
hard work of everybody in our country
not just those who get the six-figure
bonuses if I'm Prime Minister I'll take
on those energy companies that are
ripping you off if I'm Prime Minister
everyone will play by the same rules we
won't give the green light to tax
avoidance and if I'm Prime Minister will
cut the deficit every year balance the
books but we'll protect health and
education there is a big choice at this
election I believe that it's when
working people succeed that Britain
succeeds if you believe that - I ask for
your support and let's bring the change
that Britain needs Ed Miliband
thank you very much indeed Liam wood I
hope that what you've heard here tonight
doesn't fill you with too much despair
despite what you've heard there is an
alternative to the Westminster consensus
in favor of more cuts austerity is not
inevitable it's a choice we can have a
future where everyone has access to
decent public services where everyone
can have a decent standard of living but
not if we keep doing things the way we
always have done for a stronger more
prosperous greener wills for a Wales
that counts for a devolution
and financial settlement that is no
longer set second-rate give your vote to
plight come bury the party of wills for
Weir's to be strong like Scotland plight
Camry must be strong the more strength
you give us the greater influence we
will have let us be the success we know
we can be thank you dr from Bauer Dion
Val the young would Natalie Bennett if
you want to change you have to vote for
it I say vote for what you believe in
you don't have to go on voting for the
lesser of two evils that's how we ended
up with the tired failed politics that
we have now
if you want a fair economy a public NHS
a stable climate vote for change vote
green already in Parliament we've seen
Caroline Lucas make a huge impact
we need more MPs like Caroline with a
strong group of green MPs we can deliver
a new kind of politics you can deliver a
peaceful political revolution wherever
you are in England Wales Scotland or
Northern Ireland if you're thinking
about voting green do it your vote will
count Natalie Bennett Thank You Nigel
Farage you see I warned you at the
beginning I said they were all the same
what you what you've seen tonight is the
politically correct political class all
they're very keen to be popular on the
international stage they don't
understand the thoughts hopes and
aspirations of ordinary people in this
country they are detached most of them
have never had a job in their lives what
we represent in you Kip is plain spoken
patriotism we believe in this country we
believe in its people we think Britain
can be a lot better than this but if you
want things to be shaken up and to
change properly you've got to put more
you Kipp MPs in Westminster we won two
by-elections last year we can outshine
all expectations on May the 7th let's do
it not refresh thank you David Cameron
thank you I've been your Prime Minister
for the last five years and all that
time I've tried to have one task in mind
above all others and that has been
turning our economy around putting the
country back to work and clearing up the
mess that was left to us I want to stand
for another five years because I want us
to finish the job that we've all started
we've created two million jobs let's
create a job for everyone who wants and
needs one we've cut the deficit in half
let's clear it all together and have
Britain back in the black we've invested
in our national health service let's
keep doing that and make sure it's a
genuine service seven days a week for
you and your family all year round what
my
is about is basically one word security
security for you for your family for our
country this is an amazing country and
we're on our way back and there's a
fundamental choice at this election
stick with the plan and with a team who
brought that plan because it's working
and it's helping or put it all at risk
by the people who gave us the spending
the debt the taxes and the waste I say
let's stick to the plan that's working
let's not go back to square one let's
finish what we started